[Music]
today we learned the inspector-general
intends to release his much-anticipated
report on the DOJ and FBI one week from
today Michael Horowitz revealed the news
in a letter at a Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Chuck Grassley the IG
will also testify before the Senate on
the 18th now we have been told that the
report would cover just the FBI's
investigation of the Hillary Clinton
email scandal but the IG report could be
much broader as Grassley titled the IG
hearing examining the Inspector
General's first report on Justice
Department and FBI actions in advance of
the 2016 presidential election lots of
ground to cover here with California
congressman and former oversight chair
darrell Issa former US Attorney for the
Southern District of New York Daniel
Goldman and investigative reporter Lee
Smith whose work we've highlighted on
the angle okay congressman let's start
with you you've been around the block on
this stuff what what gives you think
this is gonna be a broader report why
would Grassley title it the way he
titled it well first of all because
Michael Horowitz has been around a long
time he's done a lot of investigations
of the problems the Department of
Justice in a previous administration
that wouldn't deal with those problems
even when they were reported to Congress
so I think first of all that's gonna be
part of it is he'll be asked questions
that we know from the past he can speak
on and second of all when you look at
the endemic misconduct of of Comey
including for example the Apple scandal
where he claimed you couldn't get
information it turned out not to be true
or the various handlings of Hillary
Clinton from the very time he came in
you know it gets broad pretty quick and
especially when you look at other
decisions that may have happened
including obviously the FISA warrants
Lee lots of things are bubbling up to
the surface this leak that came out
yesterday now to say that Comey was
insubordinate and defied Authority and
that Loretta Lynch didn't handle the
tarmac meeting
well if that's there even legally yeah
yeah that's if that's all they have is
that a big bombshell or is it mean if
that's it I think people gonna be
disappointed by this
I mean there's a lot of anticipation
maybe it has been built up too much
there is certainly an enormous amount to
cover though and I think that that my
answer why why senator Grassley has
titled this as well we'll be looking at
a number of things and also if you just
look the public is keen the public keeps
hearing things the public keeps hearing
leaks we keep hearing that this is being
pushed back they're looking at this this
is being blocked I think they're eager
to get out a number of these different
things before it interferes too much
with the election cycle I think these
are very I think that I think that's one
of the key issues Daniel one of the
issues that popped up today was with
Papadopoulos george papadapolis his wife
is saying that she believes the
approaches made to him could indicate
that they were trying to entrap him use
him as this way to push this
investigation forward what is your
reaction to that well legally it's not
entrapment if there's any indication
from an individual that they're willing
to do whatever the conduct is so I think
she's using perhaps a colloquial
definition of what entrapment is and
what we do know is that George
papadopolis made some drunken comment to
the Australian ambassador to the you to
the UN and that that spurred further
conversation it was reported though down
that he had hits he knew that there was
lots of emails out there Clinton emails
but then that was they backed off from
that and said he had that they had dirt
on Hillary right that's so that story
had shifted that's a big difference
someone has dirt on Hillary and someone
knew that there were emails that were
hacked and were gonna be released the
only thing I will say is having spent
ten years in the Department of Justice
and having had cases that were reported
on by the news media and no offense to
you Lee but generally speaking about 50
percent was right and it's not
necessarily the journalists fault
sometimes the sources are a little too
far removed and they don't have as much
of the information as you would like so
let's not jump to conclusions as to what
actually was in that meeting I think the
broader point here is that there was
some indication that Papadopoulos knew
that Russia had information that he was
trying to get access to and at that
point it
absolutely incumbent upon the FBI to
investigate that to see if there's a
national security risk of any sort you
don't think anything happened before
that period of time I mean you don't
think there's anything of these text
messages December 2015
they were looking at Trump and they're
talking about the the lures inside you
know putting lures inside again we don't
know really what that was about that one
unredacted text but that that's just
some weird stuff again maybe it's just
all innocent and they were having lures
all over the place I mean I'm sure they
do but something about this just just
sticks in my craw I want to play
something for you about the informants
because Kevin Brock who actually
supervised the rewriting of the rules on
informant for the FBI joined us last
week the week before on the angle let's
watch what he said an FBI agent can't go
out and just open up a source and gather
information willy-nilly they've got to
abide by the guidelines and the
guidelines are very specific
particularly in counterintelligence
investigations and even more
particularly when when you are directing
your source towards an American citizen
guy who rewrote the rules congressman
well you know and that's why when he
said you know you're it's incumbent
that's hogwash the fact is every single
political campaign Senate house
presidential they're all looking for
dirt they want it wherever they'll get
it they pay for it they hire attorneys
we paid for the dossier they'll hire law
firms to office investigating the whole
thing if the Department of Justice / the
FBI investigated every time there was a
credible attempt to get dirt no matter
where the source you'd be investigating
hundreds and hundreds cob viously is
different if it's the source of the
information is a foreign country than if
the source of the information was
someone within the country vague Alec
vague allegation that there may be
something is very different than well we
have Russian intelligence and let's
remember in this case at some point the
Department of Justice knew that in fact
the DNC and Hillary Clinton were part of
the source of that of that long after
this lightly
no I'm Vonnie for the election I'm very
uncomfortable actually with the idea
that the FBI
is running agents and opening
investigation based on what a campaign
team member says and is overheard in a
bar I think that's peculiar
I think if we were to go out to a bar
and have a conversation and the FBI and
I'm on a campaign you're on a campaign
and the FBI says let's run an
investigation on that guy I think that's
not we want to see the FDIC what Lee is
saying there well look especially during
a charged political season with this
guy's like a minor dude like he's not
anything but that's why I think you got
to recognize the investigation did not
start we don't know when it started
no we don't I'm not talking about the
time man I'm saying my eye I would I
would bet a lot of money that when they
started this investigation they had no
idea who was involved they didn't think
I'm sure at the beginning that it went
to Donald Trump or went anywhere that
high they were following a lead of a
very suspicious and specific statement
is my guess that George papadopolis gave
to somebody else and they're gonna chase
that down as you would want them to do I
think to make sure that nothing to
various is going that bill pre-snap trip
to London in May of 2016 did that does
that seem I think it's unclear right now
exactly where that is but but but I will
say that like we don't know whether or
not what kind of mechanism that this was
transmitted to the FBI
it suggests it was a regular so the idea
that it came to the State Department is
an issue fantastic conversation it's
very complicated stuff we really
distilled it well it's simple is or at